[Musik]
viel spaß
die hin und tag wünscht dr das ist schon
klar dass die piste extrem attraktiv von
dunklen schwarz
[Musik]
islam
die kerle
[Musik]
bei swiss moyo inzwischen begrenzt sei
grenze und sie frage da nicht noch was
[Musik]
wir bieten traummann jovi trainierten am
verbinden
aber sie kann menschen wohnen an trainer
wo eigentlich das ist hin und weg
[Musik]
foto martina auf ein buchstabe haft
gestellt wurde
wieso muss ihn losgegangen und dann ist
es passiert
betroffen sind wieder offen
eigentlich nicht
enthalten hat im moment verwechselte
tagen soll darauf hoffen wir sind in der
grafik sasse
[Gelächter]
wir haben viel von ihr gehört natürlich
nur gutes
also du bist der grund dass martina ihre
schwester die familie und die schweiz
verlassen will
unglücklicherweise ja wusstest du schon
immer dass die frau deines lebens eine
ausleihen drin sein wird
nein wirklich überhaupt nicht nicht von
der anderen seite der welt mich hat das
reisen nie gross interessiert bevor ich
martina traf ich ging immer davon aus
dass ich meine zeit in einer schreinerei
verbringen würde eine aufträge erledigen
und militärdienstleister und dann die
freizeit genießen mit meinem hund meinen
leuten und meinem auto und jetzt ist es
natürlich hart dass ich martina allen
wegnehmen aber eben ganz großeltern und
freunden und mir begleitet martin und
ein großer schritt
aber zuerst drei firma der ostküste von
afrika als 22 wo es unterschiedliche
kulturen und
in dem interessante russ direkt am
strand wohnt sie 2 nicole pflicht grund
sehr bekannt vor nicole berlin hat vor
über 2 im schweizer fernsehen
verschiedene sendungen moderiert denn
als sie ihre koffer packt in die 2
das ist
das city trikot
eingesprungen bin ich wenn die zittern
[Musik]
als chefin vom eigenen hotel und mut auf
der 7 jährige lila ist zieht aber zählt
nichts gut
[Musik]
dollar
ok
schon mal vor
[Musik]
die schwarze papa okay
juni
jeden morgen für mit die angestellte
bitte nicole phobie zum die
informationen über die neue desktop zone
wir haben vier neue ankünfte dann eine
abreise für lala haben wir keine neuen
gäste und vergesst die honeymoon suite
nicht
rashid der seite von nicole wo sie sich
keinen trend er polizeiinspektor der
marokkanischen stadt ist sexy
bei sondern einfach das ist immer oder
liebe seine frau mit sticks im rucksack
auf siemens zudem mit 40 das rechts
unter die ersten acht jahre hinter
rashid und nicole ist in ihre heimat
marokko bleibt vorjahr 1 das projekt als
sansibar in angriff nahm sie als chefin
und bauherrin er sie unterstützt und
ihre den rücken freihalten
[Musik]
vor städtetag bringt der klima und das
sperren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
2 kmg und wieder 20 kilometer zurück und
zum abholen
[Musik]
sansibar war nicht meine idee
ich habe das nicht gewählt der deal war
dass ich meinen job als kriminalpolizist
an den nagel hänge und dass ich etwas
neues nicht aufbauen
ich hatte eher an etwas in marokko
gedacht ich hätte es vorgezogen wenn die
line marokko aufgewachsen wäre oder in
der schweiz jedenfalls in der nähe mit
mehr zivilisation als hier in afrika
[Musik]
sie muss ja was lernen
lila gold den internationale schule für
trink von expats
[Musik]
katharina
woran also hat schweizerin mit
goldbarren und marokkaner rachida dati
verschlage sansibar die insel mit dem
klingenden namen wozu tansania gehört
geesthacht anissimow kurz begrüßt er
stets nie so richtig wie die wählen
paradis sich dort landet bin dass ich
auch privat alles da angefangen hier
der musische gestanden und es ist
generell geld baut wo die ganz neu ist
das nicht die solvenz von tierbesitzern
jobmesse für ganz schnell und zog als
wir ankamen war es noch nicht fertig
gebaut
es war so eine sache mit dem vorbesitzer
der anfang war schwierig mit dem tiefen
aus kenia als wir dann mit dem umbau
begann schliefen wir hier alle zusammen
in diesem raum nehmen ja normalerweise
wäre das die küche rot und weiß sowie
einem recht und wir haben schon denken
im text rheins und meint damit aber auch
stelle
[Musik]
berücksichtigt wenn mich so um einen
grund das muss einfach ist sich das
gehört jetzt nach zwölf jahren fünf mal
ganz schön wenn's trug die natur wurzel
und dir gefällt
nein aber es ist ihr bild mir gefällt es
nicht keine ahnung was es bedeuten soll
es interessiert mich aber auch nicht
[Musik]
platz für 220 gäste
täglich sieht elf jahres in nicole
unterschied könnte erst im zweiten
anlauf klappt der erste versuch ihre
marokkanische könig platz
das heißt wenn er war schon
sicherheitsmann von der polizei darf nur
lose könig im land ist also langsam also
irgendwelchem maria etwa also du bist in
der schweiz gesehen und gehört und dann
ist da quasi vor dem altar von
zivilstandsamt die richter hätten die
krone hat probiert durchsetzbar durch
das papier von könig und schrieb der
könig und nun probiert einfach ein flug
auf hybrid wir haben es uns unser klares
bild das wäre illegal ausreise obwohl
hier die beamten können nicht im land
ist oder als ergänzung sein
er probiert zumal 43 stück wildnis
geburtstagsfest in 40 staaten
und das ist bestätigung
mit dem salz aus der hose und dennoch
york sein nein wir hatten ja schon
unterschrieben
da kannst du ja oder nein sagen es macht
keinen unterschied mehr
ich mache nur spaß
[Musik]
angefangen hat eigene facebook seite
entdeckt also sie reisen und das
matterhorn apotheke und da habe ich das
noch so spannend ist eigentlich auf
schwedisch und da habe ich das
matterhorn
[Musik]
ich hoffe ich erzähle dasselbe ich
glaube es war
ich bin nicht sicher das gipfelfoto das
gipfelfoto dachte ich mir da war dann
ein kommentar von ihr so ging es hin und
her
so begann es
[Musik]
florence und niklas in kurorten führe
zurzeit aber neue beziehung aus
verschiedenen gründen auch immer dazu
[Musik]
leo wir uns wieder manches paar wochen
abschiede
die schöne momente bleibt aber so ist
das nun mal
wir werden täglich miteinander sprechen
nachrichten schreiben und wieder zu
sagen aber wir haben dafür auch sehr
viele glückliche augenblicke
jedes mal wenn wir uns wieder hallo
sagen können dass gleich das ständige
tschüss sagen wieder ein bisschen aus
die beam nicht so viel futter tue ich
gar nicht das ist das dicke fell
[Musik]
dass ich sie lange bevor der flugverkehr
in ganz europa wegen corona virus time
brauchen ist dass es führt florence und
niklas bald viel schwieriger wird um 16
[Musik]
kabul
zu aller erst dachte ich überhaupt nicht
du kennst mich nein echt ich reiste
schon immer viel von daher war das von
anfang an kein problem
ich dachte naja geh ich halt hin und
wieder in die schweiz wo ist das problem
gut die konsequenzen
was ich vergessen habe dass ich
vielleicht mit ihr zusammenleben will
irgendwo zusammen mit 253 hunden
das habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen
vergessen ansonsten ich habe es
geschehen lassen
ich folgte meinem herzen so lange mit
jemandem zusammen zu sein ist nicht
schlecht wir arbeiten zusammen ihr
schlafen zusammen
wir frühstücken zusammen
das ist wie wenn wir statt zwölf jahre
24 jahre zusammen wären
man kann die zeit eigentlich verdoppeln
[Musik]
sid zwölf jahre sind nicole unter rasch
schutzräume und romantik über lohn sind
zwischen deiner wozu ihre flitterwochen
mit den blumen dem die auf direct was
natürlich nur zehn macht die sich die
meisten unis und dabei setzt auch um die
koalition
[Musik]
patrick ochs am spieß auf die zwei regen
im frühling und im herbst eigentlich
immer saison und trunk nicole
unterschied bis zu 40 heimische
verstromt ums jahr einen job kommen tag
für gott ohne dass neue gäste im hotel
ballardini jacket hallo ich bin die
nicole gut also dann begrüßen wir euch
mit dem welt kommen trinkt ihr dürft aus
sehen wir dass wir selbst frauen aus
italien und bloggen des kühlers dann
sagt was auch immer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nicole ist direktorin vom host ein
theater und teil von ihrem ersparten das
projekt investiert mit folge wo sie
unter rashid notfonds erhält die lokale
behörde einnahmen noch nicht so recht
wüst werde mit hugo dass nicole als frau
aus geld bringt als investorin ich sie
sofort will chromik sie aber ihren mal
hat bis zum heutigen tag greift die
aufenthaltsbewilligung über hoch war
eher umgekehrt da in facebook sie geht's
für sie die frau sofort der bewegung
geht auf ihr bezirk ist das nicht immer
einfach sie darf ich dich stören
wie sieht es jetzt aus mit einer
aufenthaltsbewilligung
die situation ist dass ich nun schon
seit zwei jahren warte aber nicole hat
die bewegung bereits ja weil sie
investoren ist und mit eigentümerin des
hotels
deshalb ging es bei ihr schneller und
wie ist der aktuelle stand hat sich
jetzt etwas geändert die
arbeitsbewilligung habe ich es schaut so
aus als bekäme ich nun die
aufenthaltsbewilligung vielleicht schon
heute sicher ja vielleicht hoffentlich
heute
ich will keine zahlen nennen die chancen
stehen bei 55 da empfehle ich euch auch
das fenster offen zu lassen da ist auch
moskitonetz davor und hinten könnt ihr
unterziehen an der kordel
das ist ein rollo damit es dunkel ist
und niemand rein gucken kann
also wenn ihr irgendwelche fragen habt
kommt zu mir
ihr seht mich daher morgens früh
gespielt
[Gelächter]
dass nicole chefin und damit eigentlich
auch die vorgesetzte von haschisch hat
sich auch viele bezieher ausgewirkt die
neue rollenverteilung und sind die
abhängigkeit von der nicole ich werde
ehemalige marokkanischen polizei
inspektor einfach 7
darum nimmt der hütten neuen anlauf zum
sind statusverbesserung
erlaubt ist ein hallo minister eric wie
geht's gut ist mister ali hier können
wir ein derart endlich geschafft was die
rasche zwei york kampf mit der behörde
erfolglos probiert hat bewilligung ich
braun der druck groß genug sie herum
haggis länger dauert seither an und
übergibt am rashid lang ersehnte
dokument
[Musik]
die hauptziele in balad den satz dann
können wir jetzt teuer
vielen dank besuchen sie uns mit ihrer
familie kommen sie zum mittagessen oder
zum abendessen
danke vielmals wie so dass jetzt
plötzlich alles so gut klappt werde
wahrscheinlich nie erfahren
ein schelm wer böses denkt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
otto
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz am anfang vor allem ohnehin keine
kleidung ccc und so und es ist definitiv
weg sie aus dem ferienort der horex und
martina strutz und kurorte und er hätten
jobwunder biete pilatus werkstatt und
forschung wichtige detail hat sich
besten sie familie vor der martina ii
direkt als zwillingsschwester melanie
und ihren freund des anderen schnell ins
herz geschlossen
[Musik]
die laufen doch so horn wäre perfekt
wenn martina und melanie einen bald
müsste für zwillingsschwester show die
sie führt durch das ist gut wenn man
schon zum zweiten mal in nur zwei jahre
alte cale und martina abwege wehrmacht
kompromiss und was sind sie bereits im
zug kommen freunde entscheidet ist meine
freunde und familie sind natürlich auch
für mich das wichtigste aber mein glück
aufzugeben mit meinen hobbys mein
lifestyle okay das war zwar nur für zwei
jahre aber also wenn du gesagt hat ist
kaum in die schweiz und bleibt für immer
ich weiß nicht was ich gesagt hätte
minute wurde auf 3 cent l und martina
die eigene wohnung trend und sind birnen
älteres buchs und man merkt schnell auch
wenn sich die ganze familie für das
glück von deiner wahrheit erfreut
einfach wird der abschied nehmen vor
[Musik]
wo sich alles immer wieder neu an
twitter für sie kurz ich habe genau
gleich schnell kann oder mit dem moment
wo sie den court auch steht und wo
kaufen und so dass man sich nicht
einfach und bequem
[Gelächter]
das ist im januar xiii und dem iamo
denkt dass die nächste minute alles
anders und aus plant und wenn ich sage
ja sport und die wir gern mit bezahl
senders cbs tische zecken ihr für euch
wacker der minister sagen sorry machen
die warme wasser und sie gehören zur
familie und das würde franken verbaut
und dafür lässt sie zwei jahre richten
niklas aus schweden
die große lehre von florence zwang sie
aber noch im kanton solothurn wohnt gilt
der eu werk samt menschen zu verstehen
insgesamt sieben vierbeiner hat sie
früher oder später beim florence dann
ganz zum niklas zu blöd waren rabatt und
mittelschweden news
[Gelächter]
es gibt auch momente wo ist das ein tag
wo nie wirklich gegangen was sie da
machst du schon gedanken oder wenn es
ist schwer aber es ist gut geworden
so war ich nach einer sehr schnell
wieder im hip hop sie mit 101 wieviel
übrigens garnitur im gegenteil
im bau
der grund wieso jährige ist eigentlich
meine tochter neuer gibt sagt oppel
und wie schnell er hier und sie ist also
sie hat psychisches problem war sehr
schwierig ist im alltag es auch nicht
sagt kroh und einfach einen knoten muss
sie dressieren dort aber ähnelt mit den
zyklen florence und ihre tochter zieht
für ein grundstück in schweden bis das
wird florence und ihre tiere
bezugsbereit ist doch die natur
[Musik]
der nikolaus wie bringen wohnt in
jönköping im süden von schweden 26
aber er hat zwei erwachsene kinder - und
ihn ja und das ist ein test und ja ich
hatte noch nie einen hund
doch dann traf ich diese frau und die
hat 2 300 von denen und weil sie
irgendwann hierher zieht und mindestens
268 hunde mitbringen wird will ich nun
versuchen mich daran zu gewöhnen
das ist leo den ich zu testzwecken von
ihr mitgenommen habe den blinden leo ist
schon ein ja bei mir
wir haben es gut miteinander solange er
nicht in mein bett kommt ich habe
nämlich eine leichte hunde allergie
wahnsinn mit 78 runden zusammenzuleben
und allergisch zu sein - und denn ihr
könnt ihr kurz zum hund schauen
gemeinsam schaffen
im gegenteil es zeigt höchstens wie
ernst es ihm ist ganz erspart die hat er
klar zum physik und florence als
traumhaus im waldbau natürlich wenn sie
in einem halben jahr sagen würde ich
komme nun doch nicht wäre das schlimm
ich wäre wie soll ich sagen
finanziell ruiniert
[Musik]
sie hinderten niklas übrigens nicht groß
mit die bezogen
florence plan für das neues leben
geschmiedet hat auf der hochzeit kann
sie nur indirekt erfahren
[Musik]
keep it clean
wohin furchtbar duh schlägt also wähler
weniger extrem gern schön gespielt und
sehr wohl das ist schweinefleisch und
dass überhaupt nie cool wenn ich gehe
das zu weit und sieg war das kind da das
mag ich gar nicht das hat mit
gegenseitigem respekt zu tun
es geht nicht um religion sondern darum
dass ich mitbestimmen will was sie ist
aber sie liebt es das ist mir egal es
geht um erziehung das ist ein kind im
augenblick entscheiden wir noch was sie
ist ich mag die regeln nicht
bitte nicht mehr wir brauchen salami gar
nicht erst aufzutischen wenn sie da ist
wenn sonic wird im hotel bahn ag nicole
der raschid und lila ashley zieht führen
und nachlässe den meisten simret strand
vom hotel
juni perfekt
das ist super g kleine sitz auf der
andere sieht in den nachkriegsjahren
jede gasse die wie man sich es vorstellt
[Musik]
und gottfried startnummer auch michael
hat sich ihren traum vom hotel erfüllt
im raschi zentrales sie mit nicole
seiner familie zwar im moment dazu bei
die das was ich immer grün stand
und lief mit beiden kompromiss machen wo
ihnen nicht leicht vorne
[Musik]
st
hin und weg
[Musik]
um mehr lernen das war keine show von
der größe her unterschiedlichen krönte
sie claudia und ihren basketballprofi
group
eigentlich nicht üblich aber sehr
fasziniert und denn wer dort florence
dirigent und wie viel das mainufer
infiziert
[Musik]
die gerne
wer richtig machen
[Musik]
gehen und ich präsentiert wurde von dr